[Music]
namely bill hader okay so he's young
right okay I want to do the cats run in
16 parsecs mom I'm Han Solo hey aunt
Ella he's on his way to do errands or
whatever
I'm also Batman thank you okay name
please
Melissa McCarthy the Millennium made the
Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs its
parsecs car slips is funnier you need to
know is that a parsec is parsnips
they're gonna be like what have you seen
Star Wars I've seen a good portion of
one of them these are the small wizard
boy in the school in the hills
hey guys sure Thomas Middleditch han
Solo the early years han solo solo I'm
saying solo solo what the he wasn't a
lightsaber Ponce he's the guy that
doesn't have a lightsaber stair my
detonator
[Music]
oh you know when I could use young Jabba
the Hutt young driver that's like really
Jodie Foster it's the ship that made the
Kessel run in less than 12 parsecs now
get off of my plane that's from a
different Harrison Ford doesn't
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Phebe's Franklin and bash so this is
like a big spoiler like when Han Solo
you was young will see Pakistani because
I will say if you don't cast me in this
you're racist tell me the odds how's
that I'm really good at like just never
hearing the ox like the odds
no never tell me the odds
[Applause]
you never tell me though no never tell
me not this way no no what you want me
to do tell me the truth no please
[Music]
so rip before we film anything can have
a quick can I just ask this is for young
Han Solo well let's let's let's let's
give it a shot as the as the kids say
you never heard of the Millennium Falcon
it's the ship that made the Kessel run
in less than 12 parsecs yep I dialed
research believe you me what all that
means to it so I can give it a little
more credibility I'll know what we're
talking about here I'm just kind of
reading and I can't say I'm all that
familiar with the entire universe or
phraseology crazy thing is it's true the
force the Jedi all of it
hey I like that I think I get you see
what I gave you
[Applause]
who didn't young - baka is hey guys hey
when I hit puberty you better watch out
never tell me the odds okay Han Solo
doesn't use a lightsaber my version of
him does he uses a lightsaber all the
time saver
what lightsaber you get out don't be
cocky no you suck you suck it's whole
[ __ ] show how about that
[Applause]
our thanks to every single funny person
we know if we're helping us out with
that
you